the deniers have naturally caused
climate change are saying that two
degrees of warming will be disastrous
and that it will destroy agricultural
production the exact opposite is true so
glad to have our next guest on is like
he's been like my white whale I have
been chasing him but he's a busy man and
he's a busy man because sometimes the
people with the PhDs are do you have a
Twitter you have a Twitter his Twitter
is eco sense now at eco sense now when
it's not their actual name I'd always
have a yeah I'm remembering it but he
was one of the original members of
Greenpeace PhD in ecology if I'm not
mistaken dr. Patrick Moore thank you for
being on the show sir great to be with
you Stephen well we're always glad to
have a dissident on the program so for
people who may not be familiar with you
first off I want to make sure I'm
getting all of this right at the top you
have a PhD in ecology correct that is
right and actually when I started my PhD
in ecology the word was not yet in the
popular press it was a word that really
nobody knew the word environment had
started to come into use but ecology
which was up until then an obscure
branch of the life sciences of biology
only became popularized just around when
I got my PhD and afterwards of course
okay so to be clear you would be
considered a scientist and would it be
considered a science relevant to the
environment and climate well the reason
that ecology is so relevant to the
climate issue is the interdisciplinary
subject the ecology is about the
relationships among all the different
factors in the environment the
atmosphere the ocean the earth the Sun
the planets etc so you can make it as
big or small as you want you can look at
them the ecology of a microcosm like a
small lake or you can look at the
ecology of the whole earth or out into
the universe surface so the climate
issue if people keep talking about
climate science there is no such thing
as climate science in the sense that
climate science is a whole array of
different disciplines interacting you've
got meteorology you
atmospheric chemistry and atmospheric
physics you've got astrophysics and the
Sun you've got oceanography
you've got the whole terrestrial
biosphere with all the forests and the
crops and the soils rocks and all the
ice on the poles and all of those things
are interacting with each other in ways
that we don't understand perfectly but
we're gaining more and more insight into
it as time goes on okay well I just
wanted to clarify you would be more of a
scientist in this field than say someone
with a bachelor's in mechanical
engineering I just want to make sure
that that it seems as though I don't I
don't discount the layperson
even studying this thoroughly and having
a good mind to analyze the information
you don't have to be a PhD to to
understand the basics of the situation
in particular to understand how
uncertain how much uncertainty there is
in this subject rather than the whole
science is settled dogma that's just the
intellectual laziness I supposed to just
say the arguments over what exactly to
talk about well do I understood the
reason I bring this up and I talked
about this was I said listen Bill Nye is
not an atmospheric scientist he's not an
ecologist he may be a great mechanical
engineer now my only issue he's not by
the way he's pretty full of that he's he
pretty hated his job okay look a comedy
act it was very clear during the
Fukushima situation that he didn't
understand that some of the very basics
of nuclear physics for example right
well neither do I but I'm an idiot but I
assume he is as well him and I are in
good company but here's my only the
reason I bring this up is because I know
people are going to try and discredit
you and this very interview saying well
he's not insert XYZ and my point is
anyone can have an opinion but people
like Bill Nye they will use the argument
against someone like me who doesn't have
a bachelor's in any kind of scientific
field saying well listen I'm the science
guy so for people out there listening
this guy is as much of the science guy
as anybody out there something else do
before we get into some I would like to
get into the summon some of the
nitty-gritty because I'm very compelled
by your argument and I think a lot of
people haven't heard them but you were
were you one of the founding members are
one of the original members of the
environmental activist group Greenpeace
tell people about that
well while I was doing my PhD in ecology
I'd grown up in the wilderness so I had
a natural affinity for nature and this
time was the hippie era the height of
the Cold War and the height of the
Vietnam War the threat of all of nuclear
war and the emerging consciousness of
the environment so Greenpeace was a
synthesis of the long-standing tradition
of peaceful or nonviolent protest
against the establishment but along with
this newly emerging consciousness the
green so so green was the environment
peace was the people and civilization
and we chose as our first campaign I
joined it before it was even named
Greenpeace when it was called - don't
make a wave committee and was a member
of the first voyage to Alaska - the
Aleutians
to protest what what the United States
was doing then testing hydrogen bombs
underground there so that was a symbol
for our opposition to the threat of
nuclear war and that was the last h-bomb
the United States ever detonated so we
kind of started off with a bang Sooners
be yeah well you started off stopping a
bang so to speak let me ask so so people
we've established that what was the
turnaround when did you leave Greenpeace
what was the reason
well there's 15 years of history in
betweens n and when I laughed sure and
during that entire time I was in the top
committee whether it was the original
Board of Directors or the International
Board of Directors when we formed
Greenpeace International in 1979 so
that's eight years after it started and
then I was one of five international
directors for my final six years in the
organization as we drifted and and I
don't mean that in a negative way from
the focus on nuclear war because we also
stopped French atmospheric nuclear
testing in the South Pacific right after
a couple of years of campaigning and
then someone came to us Paul Spong his
name is a pH D - and he had been looking
after the first captive Orca or killer
whale as they were called then and had
come to found how fine how intelligent a
whale is yeah and then he found out that
the whales were being slaughtered on the
high seas by Russian and Japanese
factory whaling fleets primarily other
countries - but they were the main ones
killing like 30
in Wales a year yeah neither pretty
rough he appealed to us that we were the
only protesters that knew how to go out
in boats because we had been doing these
voyages to stop nuclear testing whereas
most protesters were just going down the
street with a placard so sounds like
Berkeley we actually got in a boat and
went out and confronted the Russian
whaling fleet off California and that
made it was in 1975 that went around the
world and was what he'd call viral today
Jung called a mind bomb at that time
okay
medium medium eine bombe was coined by
one of our ramp members and it was sent
an amazing ride but gradually Greenpeace
sort of lost the peace part because we
were now involved in all these eco
campaigns that didn't really care much
about the people who were doing the
whale killing trash so I think the
psychology changed toward now humans
were portrayed as the enemies of the
earth the enemies of nature and III just
didn't agree with that that large issue
that's being the only evil species on
the on the planet like it's too much
like original sin for me and I'm not
into that right well you know that's
untrue that you say that because orca
whales are vicious so are so are seals
sea otters their mating patterns I have
stand-up bits about this where I try and
take some pretty rough stuff in the
animal kingdom of course I use it as
leverage to make fun of vegans but when
people say animals don't treat each
other as poorly as humans do I come
again stupid some of what they do is on
dolphins for example as I'm sure you
know studying where the most mammals
they could they commit infanticide some
of them they kill for fun they they rape
other dolphins it's it's it the point is
yes the animal kingdom is not perfect
okay I want to move on so you move on
from Greenpeace because their focus
shifts great I just want to set this up
because people on the internet have a
very short attention span and then we'll
give you the opportunity to expand on it
so you leave Greenpeace you are one of
the most vocal skeptics so to say or
deniers depending on how you ask of
climate change before we get into the
reasoning before we get into the science
that I know you've
did a litany of times which many people
refuse to listen to in a nutshell what
is your position on the currently sort
of mass accepted concept of manmade
climate change well Stephen first there
is actually no proof that we are causing
the warming there's a number of reasons
to say that and that the evidence is
actually against the hypothesis that
we're causing the warming because
there's been warming and cooling cycles
all through the history of life and some
of them are longer than others like the
last ice age before this one was 300
million years ago and then it was warm
for nearly 300 million years before it
cold again like it is now so that's a
big cycle but they're smaller cycles and
the one that Ice Age we're in now has
cycles called major glaciations which
there have been over 20 of in the last
two and a half million years when the
ice age set on in the northern
hemisphere ice came in the southern
hemisphere many million years earlier
because it's completely different but
the earth has cooled gradually in fits
and starts for the last 50 million years
we are at the tail end of a 50 million
year cooling period and that is well
known and the graphs are available on
the Internet to show you that just after
the time of the dinosaurs will 15
million years after the time the
dinosaurs went extinct the earth was at
its hottest in hundreds of millions of
years for the Eocene thermal maximum
everybody knows about it they just
ignore it everyone knows about the
thermal maximum what do you have I'm
jarred so we've had these 22 major
glaciations and for the last million
years they've been every hundred
thousand years almost in lockstep with
the Milankovitch cycles which has to do
with the orbit of the earth and the tilt
of the earth varying over time so we
know that's we know that cycle we also
know that there was a Minoan warm period
a Roman Egyptian Warm Period a Medieval
Warm Period and now the modern warm
period in between each of one were
cooling periods the last one being the
Little Ice Age which began to end around
1700 as the temperature started warming
again rather than cooling right and just
for example the
time the River Thames froze over in
England was 1814 it had been freezing
over regularly for about three or four
or five hundred years before that but it
stopped then and hasn't frozen over
since we didn't cause that warming from
1700 to 1814 obviously and we didn't
actually cause this warming trend to
start at all in 1700 well I would
actually forgive me for I have to play
devil's advocate why would that be
obvious if people would argue you know
sort of because of humans and the
Agricultural Revolution and and methane
from from animals could they make the
argument that there was greater human
activity greater livestock activity
during that period which would have been
the catalyst for for warming of course
but they're just guessing there's no
reason to believe that it isn't just a
continuation of the warming that had
already started okay it isn't happening
at any more rapid or rate just going
back to the early 1900's from 1910 to
1940 it warmed the same amount as it did
between 1970 and 2000 which was the last
major spurt right all you know NASA NASA
now has so manipulated its temperature
curve as to hide the cooling that
occurred between 1940 and 1970
they've just eliminated it why do they
do that they just adjust the numbers and
why what would be the motivation for
NASA NASA to do that if there's one
point eight billion dollars in public
funding that's the motivation well see
put a sticker price on it like that same
reason they keep saying there might be
life on Mars 40 years after it's been
absolutely certainly proven that there
isn't any life on Mars they just float
the life on Mars thing every time they
want to send a rocket there so that
people will be in favor of it because we
might find life on Mars but they know
James Lovelock proved when he designed
the life detection system for the first
Mars Lander which was looking at the
atmospheric composition he proved there
was no life there you know like for
example on earth if he went to another
planet and found that there was lots of
oxygen in the atmosphere you could be
almost certain there was life on that
planet even if he couldn't see it
because oxygen wouldn't be in the
atmosphere if it weren't for
life yeah there wasn't a box agenda in
the Earth's early atmosphere yes put it
there I I know and that most humans can
survive that cannot survive without
oxygen Jared knows oh he can go down for
a long time without coming up for air so
let's get back to there's guessing with
the warming okay well first stuff you
just talked about 1.8 billion dollars
you know NASA and government funding I
know what people say right away are you
funded by big energy companies is that
where you make your living that is the
main criticism they will always try to
discredit the person or somehow question
the source so I've got to do that to be
fair here if you could answer to the
audience I am NOT in the pay of any
major fossil fuel company a few years
ago I did one public service
announcement in which I showed that the
oil sands after they are mined are being
put back to an original forest ecology
the boreal forests of Canada yes because
they're they're saying to people who've
never seen what's going on that the
boreal forest is being destroyed by the
by mining the oil from the sand which
they're actually cleaning the sand the
oil is losing into the Athabasca River
from the natural oil that's in that sand
and has been for millions of years but
they're taking it off and letting us use
it to run our cars and and so I just
wanted people to see the truth of what
is really being done here in Canada
because in New York and London and
Berlin they're telling everybody that
we're wrecking our whole environment and
it's like a pimple on an elephant I mean
the boreal forest is ten percent of the
world's forests right a Canadian boreal
forest yeah well I you know I have to
ask that question because you know
that's going to be those are the Spears
that always come out if someone of
course plenty of Spears that you have a
scientist is the original one with
people like me in which they're correct
okay so here's kind of as a layman for
me where I say okay it seems like the
earth is warming I'm not entirely
convinced that men are the main cause of
it or that it will have catastrophic
results and I'm certainly not convinced
that the EPA or the Paris agreement was
at the Kyoto Protocol before or I
watched Ted Turner propose China's
one-child policy to be enforced globally
I'm certainly not far enough along down
that trail but it does seem to be that
the earth is warming
are you saying that it is warming in a
temporary scale but in the grand scheme
of the timeline of the earth it's not
statistically significant and we don't
know that men are causing it is that
kind of your presupposition there is
nothing out of the ordinary with what is
happening now in any parameter you can
name temperature atmospheric chemistry
etc over the last 20 million years
nothing nothing is happening now that is
more radical than things that have
happened during the last 20 million
years even during the last ten thousand
years which is the interglacial period
were in now where it's remained fairly
steady at a higher temperature than it
was during the depths of the last
glaciation which began to end about
18,000 years ago and was sort of
officially over about 10,000 years ago
as those huge glaciers melted and so
here we are now in the Holocene which
was actually warmer 95 to 9,000 years
ago than it is now we're also in a
cooling period over that length of time
okay the only warming period we're in
now is from 1700 at the peak of the
Little Ice Age or the depths of the
Little Ice Age as it it would be better
called okay and and so that's that so
there's there's patterns on patterns on
patterns well let me ask you this though
because what they would argue is well if
you look at those periods during
millions of years ago we didn't have
civilization like we do now so assuming
that there is a you know a 1 degree I
think average per century or 1.2 degrees
per percent rates are saying if that is
the case let's say humans aren't the
cause of it or we don't know would that
have catastrophic results with modern
civilization because people live in
places like Miami would it harm farming
right now would it harm the growth of
industry would there be famine and
plight because obviously the
temperatures that occurred when the
earth was very deficit desolate don't
have the same results as they do with
billions of people well the earth wasn't
desolate during the warm periods it had
more vegetation than it does now more
forests and more green in other words
because it was wetter right and the
reason it was wetter is because it was
warmer so there's two reefs
why additional co2 in the atmosphere are
entirely beneficial the first is a
slight warming would be beneficial and
it doesn't look as though there's going
to be anything more than a slight
warming the catastrophists just
exaggerated out of all proportion and
doom and gloom the end is nigh the world
is coming to an end in 10 years if we
don't do something 10 years later it
hasn't happened and then they predicted
again because people forget that they
predicted 10 years ago that it was going
to be gone in 10 years that's how the
doomsday prophets have always worked
from the beginning of time they take a
reasonably long time period like 10
years and say if we don't act today in
10 years we will be doomed right and
then 10 years goes by the ice caps are
still there Al Gore predicted they'd be
gone a few years ago they're still there
and then they he's saying it again now
yeah right exactly the same thing he
said before which did not come true and
they get Nobel Peace Prizes for this
it's all through history people have
honored those who proclaimed
doom is coming so I don't understand I'm
not a psychologist it must have
something you loose in technology well
the ice caps have the Antarctic ice caps
have grown the ice caps have shrunken to
a significant degree is it yes that's
because it's becoming warmer you see the
big disconnect is between yes it's
becoming warmer yes
co2 is increasing due to our use of
fossil fuels but there's no proof of any
causal relationship there and the best
example of that is ice cream consumption
and shark attacks they are in perfectly
on ice cream consumption consumption and
shark attacks okay follow each other
perfectly in pattern whenever shark
attacks are high high screen consumption
goes up it's a fact and that is because
the strong correlation there is based on
a common third factor temperature people
go swimming in the summer and eat ice
cream in the summer because it's warm
and that's why shark attacks and ice
cream consumption are heavily correlated
and a key message there is even when
factors are almost perfectly correlated
it doesn't mean there's a cause-effect
relationship
between the two necessarily there may P
you have to prove it when they haven't
proved it with co2 and temperature in
any shape way or form not even slightly
and if you look back in history I've got
all the graphs from different you know
different lengths of history look at
that hundred thousand year history look
at the eight hundred thousand year
history the two and a half million year
history the five hundred million year
history co2 and temperature are out of
sync
more often than they are in sync and the
reason they're in sync sometimes might
be a whole slew of other factors that
just happen to be affecting them to go
in the same direction but that doesn't
mean there's a cause effect relationship
and it's very very clear in my mind from
all I know and I know the last 35 years
I've been looking at this and study it
every day that this has turned in to
actually a scam there it by now it
should be really hot and everything
should be drying up and the pole should
be should be dead deserts or whatever no
ice right but now if people were right
in their early predictions yeah they
were wrong and everything is going along
just fine so a little bit of warming
would be a wonderful thing like I always
say why are there 300 million plus
people in the United States and only a
few more than thirty million people in
Canada 10% by our country is larger than
yours
Wow and yet there's only 10% the number
of people here there's only one reason
for that one word cold it's just what
you would think would be more in Canada
too because with the cold and the strong
beer and not a whole lot to do you'd
think there'd be a population boom
mm-hmm
you would except there isn't enough food
to support that many people here we
could you know we jet a lot of our food
in right we do grow a lot of food in
Canada but we can't growth fruits here
like the like the tropical fruits the
key thing to understand about that
though with relation to people surviving
in a warmer world is that we are a
tropical species we are not an Arctic
species like penguins and polar bears
right we are a tropical species evolved
at the equator and the only reason we
were able to come out of africa was fire
clothing and shelter with other species
don't look you know
furry animals that live in the northern
part Arctic places they did dig a hole
in the ground and get underneath the
frost for the winter yeah that's just
what they have to do in order to survive
so the closer that when you go from the
equator to the North Pole every step of
the way
the species numbers decline and frost
and ice are the key one that makes it go
off a cliff because there's only a
select number of species that are
adapted to survive in sub-zero
temperatures when it's freezing but what
about the enemies of life what about the
coastal cities what about natural
disasters like tsunamis could a a 1
degree 2 degree temperature rise wipe
out a lot because now we do tend to live
on the coast and that's a byproduct of
as you said sort of economical have a
revolution you know with trade occurring
by boats occurring by plane places like
New York places like Miami places even
like Los Angeles or in Japan could they
see some serious negative ramifications
from just a 1 or 2 degree rise no ok
water the one or 2 degree rise is not
enough to do that ok when we came out of
the last glaciation the temperature rose
relatively quickly in time from you know
enough to cover the whole of the
northern hemisphere practically and ice
right down into the northern tier US
states and covered most of Russia that
melted and the sea went up over 400 feet
as a result of that melting and that was
just 10,000 years ago right so we have
to expect that natural climate change
and nobody's going to argue that that
wasn't a natural climate change and it
would that was climate change when it
went from really cold to just cold like
it is now because I'm I'm more than
halfway to the North Pole from the
equator here in just barely halfway to
the North Pole from the equator and it's
cold where I am there's still lots of
snow on the mountains it's supposed to
be springtime sounds like one of our
coldest winters in years here and that
is why even though I will not make a
prediction about the future because I
know it's not
possible to be certain and that the
prophets of the future are almost always
wrong anyways the the the the hypothesis
that the solar cycles of maximums and
minimums and we're now entering what's
called a grand solar minimum where the
Sun goes quiet for perhaps decades and
that allows the cosmic rays to come in
to our solar system whereas when the Sun
is in its active state with lots of
sunspots it's actually sort of fending
those off right and the theory is that
cosmic rays affect cloud cover by and
and it is its act this is actually
science beyond me even even and I know a
lot about science but when it comes to
really complex physics like that that's
it's not really my bag but that's the
Russians have been saying this for a
long time and many other people too
there's people all around the world in
the scientific community that are
watching this particular pattern of
change which is the grand solar minimum
theoretically taking us now into a new
cooling period that will be temporary I
want to touch on that real quick because
we wrote about that at the website later
with credit calm and I believe it was
NASA Courtney wrote about it we'll get
an overlay here where yes they were
saying there will be half a degree
I believe cooling period over the next
half a century but they said but then
after that human-made climate change is
still going to lead to catastrophe and
my antenna went up listen we wrote about
it and people of course say well this
isn't misrepresenting no the guy who who
made who created this study who made
this claim still said manmade climate
change is going to be a problem
what it doesn't matter what happens
Steven right the the earth it could Ice
Age could descend upon us and they would
say it's just temporary it's gonna come
back to be a disaster well my issue is a
layman is they look at that say if a law
degree will be if it gets cold right and
I look like this again half a degree if
it gets two degrees colder that would be
one hell of a lot worse than getting two
degrees warmer because it affects
agriculture yes
agriculture that the deniers and I call
them the deniers because they're denying
the actual evidence of what has actually
happened over the history well played
the the the deniers of naturally caused
climate change are saying that two
degrees of warming will be disastrous
and that it will destroy agricultural
production the exact opposite is true it
will make vast tracts of Canada and
Russia which is where most of the land
is in the world make them so you can
grow food there you don't have to go
many miles north of the US border into
Canada and all of a sudden you can't
grow anything there because it's
freezing cold eight months of the year
yeah you know in Russia they've learned
to use greenhouses in many of their more
northern places they have they actually
have some population in their northern
reaches but that costs a lot of money to
do that it's yeah you know they've got
huge diesel electric plants running
because they're off the grid way far up
north now Russia is building floating
nuclear reactors to float down the
rivers or to tow around and come up the
rivers to these settlements in the North
sure sounds like a good idea yes that is
just it makes your head spinning and the
media doesn't even pay any attention to
it Russia China and India are now all
ahead of the United States and nuclear
technology that scares me but I want two
questions so I want to go back to the
the NASA issue with the solar radiation
patterns so we brought that up and to me
just as a layman it's remarkable the
inconsistency where they say a 1 degree
rise in a century can be catastrophic a
half a degree drop in half a century
will be no big deal and then we'll go
back to manmade climate change and of
course as you're talking with the
Russians I can't member the guys name
Mehta said of something at the poke of
absorbant there's a hard name published
the website was even website the next
grand solar minimum yes and they
predicted it actually this one scientist
back as far as 2007 2009 he predicted
would begin between 2012 2015 so it was
off by a couple years but now it's
starting still a better prediction than
Al Gore mind you but let me ask you this
this is what people are going to be
asking here because the science is very
compelling and and I can listen to
someone who's a climate change
catastrophist
and go well that sounds convincing
people will say well how is it that why
do you think you've caught it
and all the scientists all this
consensus and science they've missed it
and you've caught it and they'll say
you're a quack how do you respond to
that why do so many in the scientific
field agree on this concept of
catastrophic manmade climate change you
will find that nearly all that do
believe that it's catastrophic are
publicly funded the private sector would
never fund this kind of crap the private
sector funds things that maybe some
useful is going to come out of it
something you can that people actually
want the the the climate fear campaign
is is producing fear that is its main
product is to scare people into thinking
that doom is coming and it works really
well with many people but the fact is
the consensus hypothesis is crap - it's
a fabrication
there is no peer-reviewed document that
actually does a proper job of analyzing
what how many scientists believe it's
catastrophic and how many people don't
you can vote you can believe it's
natural or you can believe is partly
man-made or you can believe it's mostly
man-made that doesn't mean you believe
it's catastrophic
right you have to say I believe as as
Obama did it's real it's man-made and
it's dangerous right you have to go all
three steps now it is real no doubt
about that and and there's no scientist
who denies that the earth has warmed but
we do know that NASA and NOAA have both
minute manipulated the data set to make
it look like it's warm more than it
actually has we know that for a fact but
it has warm that's a different issue
right whether it is good or not is
another question and whether it is
man-made or not is another question
these are other questions and so some
people just wrap that whole thing up
into one big ball and say humans are
causing catastrophic climate change and
it's proven well none of those other
steps are actually proven right so I
know people they do bring out those
charts and of course there's the hockey
stick graph which then they said was
debunked but then they actually the
person who debunked it you know again
questioned the source no no the Internet
the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change has
scarred idiot Michels carnot reputable
site the reputable scientists that are
on the side of the human caused climate
change because they're employed by the
IPCC Wu's only Mandy is to look at human
caused climate change yeah and so if the
IPCC said it isn't caused by humans that
would be self abolition so they are
inherently conflicted by their own
mandate that's the worst problem with
this at an international level is no the
Russians are the main ones who are
looking at natural causes of the cycle
but here's the most important point a
consensus is not a scientific word sure
it has no place in science and never has
it is the refuge of scoundrels who want
to stop dialogue right right Michael
Crichton said that yeah and he's right
and the fact here go back in history
they actually dared to use the Flat
Earth as an example of how the the
climate change sceptics are flat
earthers yeah right actually everybody
was a flat earther that was the
consensus Galileo and Copernicus and
others proved that to be wrong they were
they were in a minority they weren't the
consensus Darwin was in a minority
Einstein was in an immoral minority
among his colleagues who believed that
Newtonian physics was correct and
perfect and Einstein came along and
brought in relativity and at a certain
point 100 scientists signed a criticism
of his theory of relativity saying he
was wrong
and Einstein's reply was why 101 would
be enough that is true in science all
through history it only takes one person
to see you know Faraday's understanding
electricity and and Darwin understanding
evolution and Mendel understanding
genetics you know these are modern
figures so go back to Socrates he was
one against all right and so we have to
destroy this idea that consensus has a
place in science consensus is a
political and social word meaning the
people agree and all voted for this most
of them vote
and consensus is a difficult word
because it doesn't mean unanimous
agreement right
it means most it and well then what
what's the difference between consensus
and unanimity is that in in consensus
there are people who disagree with the
majority view there's every chance that
they are right at any point in time of
the dialogue because they often turn out
to be right and so therefore they must
be right sometimes if they are right now
it happens it's happened all through
history that even one person can be
right and everybody else is wrong and
that's how science works that doesn't
reflect consensus that's fascinating two
more questions before we leave and
Nikita do you have any questions that
you wanted to toss
I'm only convinced that a certain
someone doesn't give a damn about the
polar bears yes exactly clearly Pat
Moore does not care about the polar
bears they're soulless killing machines
they hunt humans all right two questions
you mentioned the if it goes up a degree
or two degrees the increase in climate
that it would make sort of this Alaskan
or this tundra a wasteland up there in
Canada maybe semi inhabitable or a place
where you could farm on the flip side of
that and I've heard this argument from
climate change activists a one or two
degree increase could that prove
catastrophic and create famine in places
much further south for example and you
know the African Sahara places like
Zambia where you know they have
difficulty growing food could could
there be that end result there no okay
good not and the reason for that is when
the pole when the earth warms and cools
it does so exorbitantly towards the
poles so three million years ago all of
Canada's Arctic islands were forested
with giant camels in them the camels
originated in this side of the world
actually and they migrated the other way
when we came this way so did the first
the horses it's an interesting story but
it's too long for this but the it is it
the long and the short of is the people
who came this way ate all the camels and
horses over here the people on the other
side said wow those things look useful
and so they didn't eat
them and the whole silk the whole silk
trade silk trail was based on camels and
then there's a reed irate horses of
Arabia so so it just goes to show you
how stupid the people that came this way
work I think it could be used that's
we've talked about that that's a big
part of the native at this sort of idea
of Native American germ warfare yeah
well biological warfare years before
germ theory they hadn't domesticated the
horse they were coming in contact with
animals yeah it apparently started here
went there we're coming back and of
course you're going to get sick it could
have used a fat prior to moving back
then it seems like it seems think it
would have been used millions of years
ago ok so it's a no but how does that
again the question is people in in
Africa south of the Equator their crops
wouldn't dry up they wouldn't see heat
waves that could destroy their their
agriculture five to between nine and
five thousand years ago so for four
thousand year period after the ice
retreated and we came into this
interglacial period the Sahara was green
and there were goat herders all over it
writing things on rocks so we know that
to be a fact and it was a little bit
warmer than one or two degrees warmer
than it is now and so what's the
deciding factor there if it was warmer
and it was more lush more water being
evaporated off seventy-two percent of
the world's surface which is the oceans
and thereby more rain falling on the
land so a weather warmer world a warmer
world will almost certainly
categorically be a wetter world there
may be some places where it gets drier
but there'll be a lot more places where
it gets wetter and you know this is just
a fact that in a warmer climate they'll
be more moisture in the atmosphere and
that will maybe make more my mind doctor
more I mean I honestly that's one thing
that I hadn't really considered I
thought well ok I think that as a layman
I think that in in the northern
hemisphere things could you could
probably grow more now you probably see
some die-off in the southern hemisphere
I didn't think of the overall
consequence of warming resulting in you
know precipitation evaporation cycle the
other factor though Stephen that's
really important is when the earth warms
it can warm five degrees on the pole and
not hardly warm at all at the equator it
warms more to
towards the polls both ways again it
does at the tropics the hottest places
in the world are not at the equator
they're at about 30 degrees 20 to 30
degrees where the Sahara Desert is where
the driest places with the less clouds
the the equatorial zone is very cloudy
and wet rain for after all the
rainforests are in Indonesia and Amazon
in Brazil yeah and in the Congo of
Africa that's the equatorial rainforests
that movies are that they are you know
we are a tropical species I come back to
that all the time yeah we couldn't live
where we do now
and what the hell are you doing up there
in Canada hold on McAdoo it has a
question we got kicked out by the people
further south I think yeah I understand
you're not a weatherman ologist that
said do you think I feel as though you
see when people can't convince you that
there's gonna be catastrophic results of
climate change may make climate change
they point to oh that will scare them
with just everyday evidence of oh see
there's a storm in Ohio regular weather
you regular weather patterns as aware of
a way of convincing people of climate
change do you see that as part of a
strategy of these these alarmists to try
to take very tangible hey there's a
drought in California or in musicality
there's a ballot there's super irregular
weather patterns it's a well known as a
well known diddy that first it was scuba
warming and then when it stopped warming
they changed it to climate change and
then they blamed everything with the
climate whether it was colder hotter
drier or wetter they blamed everything
on climate change then and then when
when that didn't bear out they went you
know they sorry you would say to them
well what about last winter it was
really cold and they will say they would
say well that's not climate that's just
weather right the climate is different
than weather now all you hear is extreme
weather because that's all they've got
left to latch on to is a big rainstorm
or a big snow storm suddenly the
California record snow storm is part of
climate change right and part of so but
the truth is if you google Roger Roger
he'll keep e ie l ke Junior
who's that Boulder Colorado a tenured
professor who studied catastrophic
events not just weather but the amount
of loss of economic loss due to extreme
weather and all at old area it's been
reducing now for years especially the
loss because we're built we are capable
of building things which stand up to
extreme weather but the extreme weather
has gone down tornadoes are down
hurricanes are down drought is down and
flooding is down worldwide well you know
I only speak anecdotally that where we
can speak anecdotally where you know I
have family in Texas and it's very very
lush and green
whereas when they moved to Texas ten
years ago was very very dry yeah and and
brittle and brown and remember up in
northern Michigan Lake Michigan everyone
there had to move their chairs back a
little bit where they had in the beach
because the lake was so shoes were
almost gone yeah even-steven today the
United States has the lowest level of
drought 7.4 percent or something then
since they started the drought index now
they didn't start it in the 30s so it
would have been a lot you know the 30s
had the Dust Bowl and so there was more
drought then but then there is then
there has been any time since then and
it was harder than in the 30s if you go
to real real client at science.com
or maybe it's org but anyways Steve
Goddard's website you will see that he
shows how they've changed the records to
eliminate the really big heat storms of
the 30s 1934 36 there were hundreds of
cities in the United States over 100
degrees on the same day in July no and
that's never happened since and yet
they've they've suppressed that now he's
got the headlines from the newspapers
and the stories that talk about it but
nobody you know everybody's memory is
like three years well they they always
claim well this isn't peer-reviewed and
he's a quack and they debunked them
because they considered a blog that's
that's what happens if unless you get
into the peer-reviewed and it seems like
it's very difficult to get any kind of
peer-reviewed published paper that's
skeptical
of this well that's the other reason
that people think there's a consensus is
because the LA Times for example some
years ago now adopted an explicit policy
of not publishing anything that
questioned manmade climate change and
many other publications have done that
both explicitly or quietly they just
don't publish it and there's lots to
publish and this whole theory of solar
activity and cosmic rays is getting
almost no press but in the background on
the Internet
there's lots of interest in it and
there's lots of people who are following
it because it seems to be him you know
Willie soon for example smithsonian
institute astrophysics was smeared by
the New York Times because the
Smithsonian takes money from companies
that are in fossil fuels
big companies that can afford to support
the Smithsonian he gets paid a salary by
the Smithsonian and he was sneered
because he's in the pocket of oil
companies right what no that's not why
he was smeared he was smeared because he
says it's the Sun stupid right right and
he shows in publications with a couple
of there's a family in Ireland that is
just amazing on this they're all PhDs
the Connolly's surprise is published
they published they published with him
showing that there's a much stronger
correlation between taller total solar
irradiance sunshine basically yeah and
the temperature curve then there is
between co2 and the temperature curve
much much stronger correlations this is
a really important paper which just
published a year or two ago it's never
seen the light of day in the popular
press right and and the Russians like
we're talking month at the the
observatory they're there their head of
astrophysics and science and came
members named they've talked about this
for a while that's kind of been his main
bag gosh we could go on forever
listen dr. more if we were able to [ __ ]
it Bill Nye or to find someone who could
have a civil dialogue debate on this
conversation would you be willing to
return and allow us to moderate it here
yeah I would I can almost guarantee you
that they will not accept right now
you've got Alex Epstein
the moral case for fossil fuels and
Leonard the NRO DiCaprio's foundation
president had agreed to debate him he's
had this is the second time at the last
minute he had a twenty thousand seat
Coliseum lined up for this debate on the
moral case for fossil fuels with the
head of DiCaprio's foundation the guy
dropped out with no explanation and no
communication to Alex yeah just
yesterday well we've had from our n2 but
but on the record you would if we could
find someone else who would agree to it
I'll debate anybody in an organized
properly organized debate structure yes
sure absolutely and the truth is you
know 20,000 Coliseum this will this if
we do it here will reach millions of
people make sure both parties agree upon
it I watched Ivanhoe yesterday and today
I'm going to use the mace and chain that
will be my chosen weapons yes
we appreciate you are a gentleman if you
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if not
there's a strong chance that you're an
armenian genocide denier wink wink I
think you know what I'm talking about
but I don't over there this isn't the
channel for you I'm sure you'll find
something there that you deem very
insightful and informative also I
request that you come back here
afterward and immediately leave a
negative comment because we read those
and those affect our lives directly we
care about them because we care about
you